[موسيقى]
مكان متعب ينخفض ​​إلى درجة التحدث
أستطيع أن أرى الصوت
أليس كذلك؟
4 كان
نعم نعم
يبدو أن الحكم غاضب من الصراخ
سوف تتعامل مع الموظفين
علقت في سيارة ارتدت من جسدي
يبدو الشمبانزي متحمسًا جدًا
أنا أصرخ حتى عندما أُرسل
د هناك نمط ولكنه قوي
يبدو أنك متحمس جدا
أعتقد أنه سيكون حوالي 30 ثانية بعد فصل مسدس الماء.
لا أعتقد أنه يعمل حتى الآن
المزيد والمزيد
سوف أمشي على حبل مشدود على السلك الكهربائي
لقد انتقلت إلى بطارية أخرى
إلى جانب ذلك ، ذهب موظفو حديقة الحيوانات إلى Gogo.
ماذا تنتشر
بدأ القرد في التحرك مرة أخرى
آه ، هل عملت؟
هل يبدو الأمر وكأنه يتظاهر؟ أنا في حالة من الإمساك بالصفوف بطريقة ما.
أحفادي على وشك السقوط ، لكنهم على وشك العودة
جسدي ممدود بدولار
ثم يحاول طاقم الحيوانات نشر الشبكة والقبض عليها
حسنًا ، لقد وقعت في الغرفة الداخلية
جائزة المال في حديقة الحيوان
أنا
دخل الدخل السنوي بالطائرة
ماكينة خياطة الشركة تقول
لكن لا يمكنني رؤيته
اه اه اه